une production du studio SF
bienvenue sans filtre le
podcasts
cette semaine cette semaine j'ai
vraiment intéressant on parle
d'intelligence artificielle puis on
reçoit une sémitée
maintenant sa propre stand up
d'intelligence artificielle de de
réseaux sociaux intelligent qui
s'appelle Weaverly et qui en fait
s'appelle weverly
Philippe Beaudoin finalement on est
rendu des robots déjà
de le recevoir en fait j'ai découvert
parce que j'ai entendu dans les médias
parler de chat di pity le sujet de
l'heure en intelligence artificielle
n'avait sûrement entendu parler c'est un
chat auquel tu poses des questions puis
te réponds sous forme de texte il peut
faire des travaux d'université à ta
place c'est vraiment malade
engendrer comme comme dans le futur
qu'est-ce que ça peut changer pour nous
puis aussi on parle d'intelligence
artificielle atlas de s'accompagner
weverly c'était vraiment fascinant
l'université j'ai appris quelque chose
par rapport à la science-fiction
puisqu'on disait c'est que si l'être
humain peut l'imaginer ça peut exister
donc éventuellement puis l'exemple qu'on
donnait c'était Jules Verne qui on a pas
l'impression que Jules Verne écrivait de
la science-fiction mais c'est pas de ce
de quoi il parlait au moment d'écrire
soit 20 minutes que ce soit le tour du
monde en 80 jours
mais
une réflexion un podcast puis
j'y repense en ce moment alors qu'on
présente le podcast puis c'est dire que
vla 50 ans on aurait même pas pu
imaginer une technologie comme chat
quand tu dis que tu peux même pas
imaginer quelque chose parce que tu peux
pas les outils puis les connaissances
puis la connaissance de la vitesse
laquelle ça peut évoluer pour imaginer
quelque chose imaginez même dans 50 ans
après le podcast qu'on fait là parce
qu'on demande quand même à Philippe
qu'est-ce qu'il pense qu'il va se passer
dans cinq ans à la vitesse quelque chose
évoluent puis c'est un gaz qui est
beaucoup plus éduqué que le nôtre mais
cinq ans ok 50 ans
sur notre place c'est quoi c'est quoi
c'est quoi une humaine en fait c'est
quoi notre place dans
dans la société dans la vie de plus en
plus que l'intelligence artificielle va
prendre de l'expansion qu'est-ce qu'on
va devenir c'est des grandes questions
qui nous guette qui est auquel il faut
réfléchir que j'espère que vous avez
apprécié cette conversation ouais bon
podcast
le podcast de cette semaine est présenté
par nos amis chez men's Kate qui moi
après moi continue de supporter le sans
fil podcast et qui moi après moi
continue de sortir des produits
absolument incroyables comme ici leur
nouveauté le widwalker 2.0 on vous a
déjà parlé du Wild Waker de base qui
était ok en fait leur tondeuse pour poil
de nez et là ils viennent de sortir le
Wild Walker 2.0 qui a une meilleure
courbe métallique qui permet de couper
mieux et plus en profondeur les poils de
nez si vous êtes des vrais fans ça en
fait podcast vous rappelez sans aucun
doute de l'épisode avec Bob le Chef où
est-ce que Bob nous
l'importance d'une entretien de poils
nasal afin de juste être la meilleure
version de soi-même donc oui Walker 2.0
vient de sortir et au-delà du Wild Waker
vous savez personnellement on en parle
sans arrêt mais il y a une panoplie de
produits pour l'entretien des poils des
cheveux de la peau avec une odeur
incroyable moi les produits masqué
honnêtement
les produits manscape
sont les seuls produits d'entretien que
j'utilise quel est je vous laisse pas il
y a pas de blague et on a laissé les
blagues l'autre côté de mes parties que
les blagues les produits médical sont
les meilleurs produits que moi
personnellement j'endose parce que
j'utilise quotidien si vous voulez
utiliser vous aussi les produits
manscrit que ce soit le Wild Waker le
lendemain le
ultra smooth package tout seul allez au
même skate sur leur site web utiliser le
code promo sans filtre pour avoir 20% de
rabais et le shipping gratuit je vous le
dis vous allez plus jamais utiliser
d'autres produits
point bas allez voir ça merci menscape
puis merci à vous autres d'écouter sans
filtre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on y va
avec une comparaison Québec Montréal là
mais Montréal c'est ingéré les tempêtes
comme hier soir je comprends que c'est
une grosse tempête mais hier soir les
routes étaient pas praticable j'ai fait
de Notre-Dame jusqu'à dans l'est
jamais
on continue la guerre mais
plus de monde il y a plus de
d'équipements puis je veux dire ça
arrive pas une route qui est
complètement pas déblayée quand même
efficace à Québec c'est vraiment
efficace
[Rires]
il y a un café qui s'appelle le café
fridant un café végan sur la rivière
aujourd'hui ouais parce que là le sujet
de l'heure puis on va commencer avec ce
puis ça va sans doute nous amener à
parler de plus largement mais le sujet
de l'ordre que la nouveauté donne tout
le monde parle des dernières semaines
c'est chat
en fait peux-tu nous expliquer c'est
quoi en gros mettons que quelqu'un qui
écoute qui a aucune idée que je
m'attendais
sur Internet on va sur des sites web une
petite chatte qui arrive c'est toujours
pourri c'est toujours vraiment pourri et
puis parce que genre moi j'ai un site en
ligne sur Shopify et puis je peux en
créer un avec des réponses automatisées
mais c'est de la merde les gens vont pas
cliquer dessus des gens vont appris que
c'était pas très bon
ça fonctionne c'est vraiment un peu
l'interface c'est tout à fait
tout ça que une boîte de textes tu peux
écrire ce que tu veux puis là il te
répond mais ce qui est impressionnant
c'est que c'est pas juste des réponses
comme précaée tu peux pas juste parler
d'un sujet tu peux parler absolument
n'importe quoi puis comme chat comme du
l'Internet en date de 2020 je pense bah
beaucoup beaucoup de sujets puis il fait
des phrases de sérieux on dirait qu'il
allait à l'université mais tu dis en
date de 2021 ça fait combien de temps
est-ce qu'il s'affairent à lire
l'Internet je sais pas dans le fond ce
qu'on fait c'est qu'ils ont pris un
snapchat de l'Internet en 2021 une copie
de tout ce qui peut pas tout tout mais
d'un gros sous ensemble de l'Internet
puis ils sont servis de ça pourra
traîner c'est un système d'intelligence
artificielle ils ont entraîné
l'intelligence artificielle avec ses
données là donc tous les livres jamais
écrit tout seul toutes les livres toute
la fanfiction de Harry Potter toutes les
études scientifiques de n'importe quel
université pas nécessaire ok donc
des choses sans plus dures à aller
chercher je connais pas exactement les
limites de ce qui a appris mais il
connaît par exemple les grands
chercheurs et c'est à peu près ce qui
ont publié mais il y a beaucoup de ces
publications là qui sont sous forme de
pdf et tout ça c'est pas nécessairement
dans le système mais il y en a dû assez
qui est capable de discourir sur un
paquet de sujet différent je puisse non
seulement c'est ça ici qui est capable
aussi d'analyser ou d'interpréter
quasiment on dirait
subjectivement des données j'ai vu
quelqu'un qui disait qu'est-ce que niche
je dirais du de la walkness puis
une réponse qu'est-ce que naïve selon
son interprétation de ce que needy puis
son interprétation de la walkness
qu'est-ce que je dirais de la walkness
moi j'ai vu quelqu'un faire petit
m'écrire un synopsis d'un film qui
mettrait en scène un personnage qui veut
faire telle affaire puis
il arrivait quelque chose de posé pareil
c'est peut-être pas un Oscar tu es pas
une palme d'or mais c'était quand même
il y avait écrit quoi exactement puis tu
sais tu peux lui dire dans le style de
tu pourrais demander qu'est-ce que deux
gars Québec dirait du neige va de
Montréal
des choses que des gens Québécois ont
écrit donc qu'est-ce que à Montréal
mais c'est ça qui était impressionnant
puis
c'est vraiment ça puis je pense que
c'est ça qui capture l'imagination
populaire le tout le monde tu le sais tu
te rends compte à quel point c'est on
est d'ailleurs là c'est quelque chose
c'est la première fois que quelque chose
d'aussi puissant puis aussi avancer
absolument puis qu'est-ce que ça change
qu'est-ce que ça va changer pour le
commun immortel dans le futur que ça ça
existe bon là
les investisseurs là les gens qui ont
beaucoup d'argent c'est qu'une vallée
New York les capotes laissant entrées de
se poser exactement cette question là
qu'est-ce que ça va changer c'est quoi
des entreprises qui vont réussir à s'en
servir pour
créer des outils de demain des
plateformes de demain tout ce qu'on veut
servir mais là il dit les gens
réfléchissent à ça beaucoup
la réflexion en ce moment se porte
beaucoup sur
le processus créatif c'est bon on a pété
qui permet de créer du texte comme tu le
mentionné ça peut écrire un synopsis de
film donc on peut s'imaginer que
peut-être des gens vont s'en servir pour
pour créer des snaps des résumés changer
de style d'un texte ok ça c'est le fun
mais j'aimerais bien que ça soit dit
comme si c'était Shakespeare que j'avais
écrit genre donc on peut faire des
choses comme ça on voit beaucoup des
utilisations créatives d'un chat GPT en
parallèle ce qui est intéressant je peux
petite parenthèse ici c'est juste
le podcasts puis à faire on les referme
pas toutes ces conneries sur un truc qui
s'appelle
midjani Dali
donc
ça c'est toutes des intelligences
artificielles sauf que le but c'est pas
de générer du texte c'est de générer des
images d'aller j'ai essayé gosser un peu
là dessus puis c'est quand même assez
incroyable c'est maintenant que tu veux
une image de
fenêtre au bord de la mer dans un
appartement
blanc avec du sable au sol puis des
livres qui volent
partageait ses photos générer modifier
sur
en arrière c'est ce qu'on appelle des
réseaux de neurones profonds puis il y a
toutes des variables mais c'est les
mêmes idées depuis c'est comme ça fait
ça fait peut-être 10 ans que on
développe ses idées là mais ça arrive à
peu près tout en même temps au niveau où
on voit des applications directes donc
ça on voit donc l'utilisation de
l'intelligence artificielle pour des
des besoins créatifs
qui font de la musique c'est beaucoup ça
qui capture d'imagination des
investisseurs en ce moment ils se disent
ah ça va ça va servir beaucoup dans les
milieux créatifs dans les domaines
créatifs on va avoir des nouveaux outils
photoshop et out Photoshop avec avec du
blabla c'est la prochaine fois
juste besoin d'expliquer qu'est-ce que
tu veux
me blanchir les dents puis il va le
faire tu as besoin de le faire toi-même
pour un graphisme
ça c'est sûr donc
du point de vue artistique on peut on
peut on peut penser qu'il y a
possiblement comme une certaine époque
des métiers qui ont été remplacés par la
machine qui fait qui fait x torche
manuel mais là maintenant ça s'en vient
dans ce domaine-là je te dirai que si
c'est ce que les investisseurs
moi je suis passé convaincu
personnellement je suis pas sûr en fait
je pense que pour de la musique
d'ascenseur on va servir de trucs comme
ça c'est peut-être pour pour illustrer
des postes
trouver le temps de vidéo ou des choses
comme ça peut-être qu'on va s'en servir
un petit peu plus
mais
c'est dans la création artistique même
je sais ce que vous faites ici ce
podcast il y a beaucoup cette recherche
du lien humain puis à mon avis va rester
il va encore avoir des créateurs ils
vont juste se servir d'outils différents
parce que ADN je pense que ce que les
gens veulent ressentir c'est il y a un
humain derrière le truc que je consomme
peut-être que cet humain-là s'est servi
d'un pinceau peut-être qui s'est servi
d'une souris peut-être qui s'est servi
de chat mais à la fin ce qui a créé ça
me permet de connecter un peu avec cette
personne j'ai l'impression
personnellement il y a beaucoup
d'artistes qui ont peur de ça puis je
comprends d'où ça vient puis en fait
c'est à nous à définir ça va mais mon
intuition c'est que il va encore ce
désir là chez les gens de connecter avec
l'humain qui crie quelque chose parce
que devenir encore plus un produit entre
guillemets de luxe dans le sens que ces
méthodes tu achètes quelque chose fait à
la main aujourd'hui c'est comme ose ça
c'est fait à la main ou bien une musique
composée
par un humain c'est comme oh ça c'est
prestigieux c'est composé par un humain
et non une machine ouais
de combien d'outils s'est servi pour
composer sa tonne c'est peut-être que ça
va être justement ça va être tchat dit
free tu sais ce livre Le garantit
mais il y a quand même un espèce de
spectre quand on parle de chat GPT on
peut le dire à chat j'ai pété écrit le
livre à ma place presque mais on peut
juste aussi juste s'en servir pour
corriger les fautes puis là on se
rapproche plus d'un correcteur
orthographique donc tout le monde se
sert à peu près aujourd'hui puis on a
pas l'impression que parce qu'on sort
d'un correcteur d'orthographique on est
plus l'auteur du texte parce que
vraiment un espèce de spectre assez
large entre
disons le correcteur orthographique tel
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui puis un livre
écrit au complet par un chat GPT ça va
vraiment être le fun de voir où
différentes personnes différents
créateurs se positionnent sur ce spectre
hier on parlait de ça justement puis on
se dit
la réflexion par rapport au système
d'éducation puis comment est-ce que on
va s'arranger pour retravailler nos
évaluations parce que si les évaluations
c'est dissertation qui que tu dois faire
chez vous ça ouvre la porte une boîte de
Pandore énorme c'est là je lisais j'ai
vu passer un publication sur Instagram
qui disait que tchat j'ai pété avait
réussi à passer les examens de droit aux
États-Unis il y a rien de plus
évident tu sais s'il est capable de lire
le code civil puis le Code criminel il
est capable de passer n'importe quel
examen de droit là tu sais sauf que si
quelqu'un étudiait en droit à une
dissertation à faire chez eux puis qu'il
y a un outil qui est capable de passer
les examens du bord haut peu importe
c'est quoi aux États-Unis l'équivalent
bah c'est le bar aussi mais ça devient
comme on va avoir une ajustement à faire
clairement pour garder des humains
performants puis pas juste des humains
qui sont capables de les bonnes
questions
en garder des humains performants versus
évalué des humains ces deux affaires un
peu différents
un peu pour les deux on va servir une
certaine pour essayer de t'aider à
apprendre à réfléchir mais on va s'en
servir aussi pour te positionner par
rapport à tes paires c'était déjà un bon
avocat c'est un avocat moyen puis je
pense que c'est cet aspect là qui va
être challenger le plus et le plus
rapidement avant quand on donne une
certaine confiance tu sais c'est sûr que
si tu fais de riche fait payer quelqu'un
pour écrire cette sensation c'est
toujours existé
mais c'était pas aussi accessible que ce
lait aujourd'hui puis là aujourd'hui
tout le monde peut dire c'est chat GPT
je vois je vais m'en servir pour faire
ça
je pense que ça va ça va chez qui un
petit peu la cage en éducation du côté
de l'évaluation comment on évalue ces
personnes là aujourd'hui c'est dans le
futur mais j'aimerais ça personnellement
que ça pousse la réflexion un peu plus
loin puis qu'on se demande est-ce que
l'évaluation est-ce qu'on
à quoi sert cette évaluation en partie
pour savoir pour aider l'employeur à
choisir je veux un bon avocat versus un
pas bon avocat bon en partie pour
motiver les étudiants en disant ben si
tu si tu dis pas tu vas avoir de
mauvaises évaluation on va avoir de
mauvaises notes tu auras pas de job
c'est je pense qu'on peut se poser la
question est-ce que c'est la bonne façon
de motiver les étudiants puis est-ce
qu'on a vraiment aidé les employeurs
tant que ça à trouver le meilleur avocat
c'est notre système d'éducation moi
c'est la réflexion que je rêve de voir
arriver là-dedans j'en parle avec
plusieurs de mes amis qui sont dans le
milieu d'éducation puis c'est une
réflexion qui se pose aussi est-ce que
on n'a pas un peu trop délégué la tâche
de motiver
au bâton de l'évaluation mais
ce qui peut
j'ai l'impression
qu'en tant qu'humanité on veut quand
même être capable de stocker un peu
d'information dans le cerveau à nous
d'être capable de faire des tâches tu es
capable de calculer déjà on pourrait
tout déléguer les technologies puis si
je publierai après la calculer j'ai une
calculatrice besoin d'apprendre à
réfléchir j'ai déjà dit mais un moment
donné est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on fait peu
plus on donne des pouvoirs plus on
délègue nos capacités à nous à la
machine
on devient pas un peu des humains moins
avancé en tant que ça c'est l'autre
partie de la question c'est au-delà de
l'évaluation il y a qu'est-ce qu'on veut
apprendre aux humains et puis nous
qu'est-ce qu'on veut comme une qu'est-ce
qu'on veut développer c'est comment on
se définit c'est quoi qui fait que je
suis par exemple à ce moment pour le fun
l'allemand ok il est pas vraiment de
raison besoin d'apprendre l'Allemagne
mais ça m'apporte la satisfaction si je
le fais je peux demander à
une traduire ce que j'ai ce que j'ai
écrit en Allemagne ça risque de sortir
quand même pas pire c'est pas pour ça
que je la prends mais je trouve que
c'est un bel exemple de on a quand même
des motivations intrinsèque qui vont
au-delà de ce que les outils nous
permettent de faire puis c'est comme ça
qu'on se définit tu sais
on a un peu perdu cette vue tu sais en
mettant la job tellement au centre de
nos vies puis en disant bah c'est mon
utilité c'est c'est la job que je vais
avoir c'est mais
toutes les toutes les évolutions qu'on
voit en intelligence artificielle je
pense que ça nous force à réfléchir un
peu au-delà de ça c'est à dire on est
plus que nos jobs on est plus que ce que
les outils nous permettent de faire moi
je décide de tricoter même si je peux
m'acheter un chandail je vais essayer
d'apprendre l'Allemagne je peux faire
traduire mon truc en allemand tu sais
c'est
une réflexion saine moi je dis l'enfant
7 20 ans puis il se pose ces questions
là que tu dis puis j'aime ça moi je me
posais pas la rage mes parents
définitivement pas fait je pense que
c'est une évolution assez normale dans
la société on se ramasse avec des outils
et challenge quasiment c'est notre
identité que ça veut dire d'être humain
un peu plus définir il y a pas un
exemple que j'aime super gros par
rapport à ça quelques années je sais pas
si vous avez suivi ça les parties de GO
entre l'intelligence artificielle puis
le lycée qui était le champion mondial
de GO ok le Go c'est un jeu comme les
échecs
lycée doll a perdu à lui personne
pensait qu'elle était à tout le monde
pensait qu'elle allait gagner lui cedol
il se définit comme le meilleur joueur
de goût au monde et pas de machine qui
peut le battre ok il a perdu la game il
est allé sur le stage puis après il
s'est excusé à l'humanité il y a
vraiment dit je m'excuse l'humanité je
vous ai fait on est dépassé on est
dépassé son
identité entière était à résidait dans
sa capacité d'être meilleur que
n'importe qui et n'importe quoi au goût
puis là il a perdu ça parce que c'était
vraiment une crise d'identitaire pour
lui je pense qu'on va aller en voir de
ça mais en même temps ça nous force à
nous poser des questions à se
fondamentales qui sont importantes c'est
comment on se définit qui on est quand
qu'on parle de ces questions-là et puis
hier on en parlait
où les Alpes
moi quand j'en parle puis depuis souvent
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a de la peur
en fait il y a de la
quand j'en parle avec toi je sens pas
aucune peur en fait
dans
une mauvaise trail pas nécessairement
absolument oui définitivement puis les
premières affaires qu'on va voir c'est
des mauvaises strayes on l'a vu un peu
avec avec Dali ces trucs là d'être
inondés d'image que ok on en avait assez
tout le monde toutes les journalistes
m'ont fait et on fait la première
chronique je vais le faire écrire par
chat super cool on va être inondé de
trucs comme ça récemment c'est sorti que
si net la grosse publication américaine
avait utilisé tchagpt je sais pas si
peut-être qu'il y avait utilisé une IA
pour générer des textes qui avaient mis
en ligne sans dire à personne puis ils
sont faits ça fait taper sur les doigts
mais il y a un vrai risque là il y a
comme
toute une plateforme de diffusion
d'information
si on génère plus de contenu si on les
met dessus plus on a plus de chances de
son nager puis de générer des clics puis
d'être visible et tout ça et un affaire
comme chat j'ai pété ou des trucs comme
comme Dali ça permet de créer du contenu
rapidement mais pas super bon tu peux
nous écrire rapidement tu peux inonder
la place publique la dernière chose que
c'est en fait c'est du contenu original
parce que ça ramasse des idées qui sont
pris ailleurs ça dépend toujours combien
d'efforts tu mettes dessus
le but c'est de pas mettre d'effort mais
oui ça va être compliqué
les e-commerce qui ont explosé d'un
dernier temps avec des blocs tu dis ils
ont une équipe de 7 7 rédacteurs pour
sortir trois articles mettons quelqu'un
qui vend des skis qui sort le bienfait
du ski tel façon les bienfaits de tel
ski puis tu fais juste m'écrire dans
chat GPT et quels sont les bienfaits du
ski donner sur le cœur sur un article au
complet quels sont les bienfaits du ski
de randonnée sur les pieds sur un
article au complet genre ça te prend en
5 minutes de l'équivalent d'une semaine
de contenu de blog écrit par un blogueur
c'est fou là
mettons je sais pas on veut on veut
générer du contenu qui génère justement
des clics mais pour dire
écris-moi écris-moi des crimes des
chroniques des Richard Martineau appelle
puis on va être encore plus enseveli des
Chroniques de Jean Martino
[Rires]
dans le style de Richard
c'est ça donc oui il y a des risques
pour prenais la question c'est le
premier que tu sais qu'on imagine qu'on
voit c'est sûr qu'il va arriver
c'est comme toutes les technologies je
veux dire on a les scientifiques puis
les entrepreneurs qui prennent des
technos et qui développent en outil
puis après ça c'est qui en
arrière on a les gouvernements les
systèmes législatifs qui essaient de
voir puis ça c'est un gros lag c'est sûr
avant que avant que les élus comprennent
la technologie passe des mois derrière
c'est quoi la forme ça vaut beaucoup
trop ça évolue trop rapidement en fait
pour pouvoir le légiférer en temps réel
le rap est un peu en avance sur
certaines de ces questions là le vieux
avec les questions du privé puis les
réseaux sociaux et tout ça
pour plein de raisons mais ouais sur ces
sur ces questions là de de gens
artificielle générative c'est comme ça
qu'on appelle des produits petits lidly
c'est clair dans ce moment il y a
beaucoup de monde qui se posent des
questions
dans dans les gouvernements à travers
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire avec ça c'est à
suivre à ce niveau là surtout en passant
tu sais que
casser les tout
débuté
dans l'impression que ça s'en va nulle
part là cette technologie là c'est
l'humanité s'embarque dans un nouvel
affaire
dentiste
je pense aussi donc on peut regarder les
gouvernements qu'est-ce qu'il peut faire
puis il faut aussi se poser la question
est-ce que est-ce qu'on peut pas
justement plutôt que de sauter tout de
suite sur les utilisations qui sont qui
vont clairement néfastes pour pour
l'humanité mais peut-être bénéfique pour
une coupe de blogueurs on peut on peut
aussi se poser la question il y a dessus
des manières de d'utiliser cette
technologie là pour aider
les gentils
de
se battre dans l'autre direction tu sais
puis c'est vraiment moi je suis
fondateur de
ça ça atteint le point le point de
bascule qui les rend intéressant pour
tout le monde mais ça fait longtemps que
ces technologies existent et nous ça
fait trois ans qu'on développe une
manière d'utiliser cette compréhension
là de ce qu'on appelle la langue
naturelle le français dans lequel la
langue qu'on parle tous les jours cette
compréhension là de la langue naturelle
que les machines ont acquises au cours
des dernières années on veut s'en servir
pour donner plus d'outils plus de
pouvoir aux gens comme comme vous comme
moi comme n'importe qui qui consomme du
contenu sur Internet puis se disent
c'est tu le contenu que je veux je donne
merci beaucoup de des algorithmes qui
sont qui sont développés par des
plateformes qu'on utilise puis notre
prétention nous de se dire mais parce
qu'on comprend la langue naturelle on va
être en mesure de donner les clés aux
gens puis dire développer ton algorithme
écrit qu'est-ce que tu veux qu'il fasse
pour toi comme tu t'expliquerai un de
tes amis puis ton algorithme tu vas voir
ton algorithme si tu veux des choses qui
sont très populaires on va mettre du
populaire sur des choses qui sont
récentes que personne a vu on va te
mettre ça si tu veux du vegan on va te
mettre du vegan mais tu sais c'est toi
qui ne contrôle c'est pas l'histoire de
tes clics des 10 dernières années qui
viennent définir qu'est-ce qu'il va y
avoir sur ton YouTube dans facebook donc
moi j'allais dire pour avant d'en
arriver à parler de weverly on pourrait
retourner juste toi personnellement ton
background ton parcours parce que
évidemment on va en parler parce que
c'est vraiment super intéressant mais
juste pour mettre en contexte un petit
peu le
comment est-ce que tu as commencé à
t'intéresser à la tech puis à
l'intelligence artificielle moi je vois
écoute
[Rires]
depuis l'université que je m'intéresse
aux maths mais c'est plus spécifiquement
à l'université je faisais du graphisme
qui a fait une 3D des trucs de jeux
vidéo sur les choses comme ça puis je
suis allé faire mon docteur
je travaillais un peu en jeu vidéo aussi
à l'époque puis je fais mon doctorat
là-dedans puisqu'on faisait dans ce que
je faisais c'est des petits robots vous
voyez les bassines dynamics vous avez vu
des vidéos nous laissons c'est fou
moi ça que je faisais mais en simulation
puis des balancer il pousse le robot le
robot est orateurs
il y avait beaucoup d'intelligence
artificielle derrière mais c'est de
l'intelligence artificielle de 15 ans
qui est complètement différent de cette
qu'on a aujourd'hui mais je me suis
toujours intéressé à ça et puis je
voulais un certain niveau je vais
devenir prof là-dedans enseignait
d'université puis
c'est dur de faire court de combattants
de profiter je vais aller travailler
chez Google j'ai fait cinq ans
mais c'est ça donc chez Google pas au
début je faisais beaucoup d'intelligence
artificielle mais éventuellement j'ai
commencé à travailler à niAme chez
Google c'est pas des robots qu'on fait
c'est
des engins de recherche puis ce qu'on
appelle des engins de recommandations
des engins de recommandations c'est le
truc c'est ce qu'on appelle les
algorithmes si c'est le choisissent
qu'il y a sur ton fil Youtube Facebook
etc
moi je faisais ça chez Google fait que
si j'avais des deux mains dans le moteur
je regardais comment c'était fait puis
je suis quelqu'un qui devient facilement
à croquer j'installe pas
la manière dont on faisait ses
algorithmes là
c'était sur Chrome le Brazzers
puis je trouvais qu'il y avait un gros
risque un gros risque de donner au monde
ce qui demande
exactement
la philosophie tu sais la philosophie
dans ses grandes boîtes là c'est de dire
demande pas aux gens ce qu'ils veulent
regarde ce qu'ils font
puis je trouvais qu'il y avait un
problème fondamental avec cette
philosophie de qui drive toutes les
décisions si je peux je sais Google mais
sur facebook j'ai toutes ces plateformes
TIC Tok c'est 100% ça puis
j'ai commencé à me poser la question on
peut tu faire
des algorithmes différents des engins de
recommandations différemment
parler de façon
un mouvement à l'intérieur de Google qui
était mené par un truc qui s'appelle
Christine Harris
vous connaissez pas mais vous connaissez
c'est le gars qui a fait de surchauffe
de la main
qui a réalisé que réalisé de
surchauffements et lui était manager
chez Google à l'époque puis la personne
mouvement interne à part un peu dans le
film ok
disait nos produits rendent des gens
accro nos produits à être pas les gens à
se développer puis moi j'étais avarié
là-dedans classique les traits circulent
à l'intérieur des compagnies il y avait
ces documents quand ça s'est rendu
jusqu'en haut j'imagine que ça job
longtemps
système d'exploitation que Google
développait pour mobile et on fait de je
pense qu'elle fait ça dès que tu es un
ensemble d'outils qui étaient disponible
dans le système d'exploitation pour
t'aider à mieux gérer ton temps puis à
mettre des systèmes caché en arrière de
63 clés là c'était pas vraiment mis de
lavable mais c'est les gens qui
cherchent qui cherchait ça pouvait le
trouver ça fait tard une certaine partie
partie des gens mais ça s'est jamais
rendu au petit truc mais les plateformes
qu'on roule sur nos téléphones et
Facebook etc on passe ça puis c'est basé
sur les mêmes gens technologies moi ça
m'est resté comment on peut faire des
algorithmes différemment comment on peut
faire les algorithmes qui s'intéressent
plus à
pas nécessairement ce qu'on fait mais
c'est des habitudes qu'on aimerait
développer la direction laquelle on
voudrait évoluer c'est les questions
qu'on se pose quand on s'arrête le soir
puis qu'on se dit je suis passé la bonne
chose de la journée que je voulais
passer je te fais des choses que je
voulais faire on se pose parfois tout le
monde se pose ces questions là puis
est-ce on pourrait pas faire des
algorithmes qui s'intéressent aux
réponses qu'on donne à ça quitte à être
moins engageant quitte à être moins
discret que ce qu'on a ce moment mais
peut-être plus proche de
d'outils qui aideraient les gens où
est-ce qu'ils veulent aller
donc ça c'est mon background après ça je
travaillais j'ai fondé une compagnie qui
s'appelle lmntry j'étais en charge de la
recherche là-bas puis je travaillais
beaucoup en recherche avec des
chercheurs qui sont 20 meilleurs que moi
en compréhension de la langue naturelle
des gens qui ont fait des chats GPT etc
c'était il y en avait une partie de ceux
qui travaillait dans nos équipes chez
lmnta et là j'ai vu
puis
je me suis dit que c'est ça la solution
c'est de servir de cette compréhension
là de cette compréhension fine et
nuancée que la machine est capable
d'avoir des mots que les gens utilisent
de servir de ça pour venir contrôler les
algorithmes contrôler nos plateformes
dans notre commémoration nos Facebook
nous Youtube c'est que quand j'ai décidé
de quitter lmntry pour partir de ma
propre famille c'était vraiment c'était
ça que j'allais faire on va développer
des algorithmes qui utilisent la
compréhension de la nature naturelle
pour contrôler nos Fides fait
concrètement mettons la plateforme ça
ressemble à un réseau social finalement
comme on connaît sauf que ça va être
vraiment je veux je veux moi exprimer
exactement qu'est-ce que j'ai envie de
voir la machine va le comprendre il faut
m'envoyer ça c'est ça
résumer simplement le c'est exactement
ça oh target plus
désolé des gens qui ont des intérêts euh
genre ça va plus par la communauté des
des
LinkedIn un peu parce que c'est ceux qui
sentent plus le problème aujourd'hui on
va être moins dans l'entertainment plus
dans l'information dans l'information de
l'information pointue puis des
conversations aussi le genre de
conversation avec du monde ça ça serait
mieux ce genre de conversation là c'est
ça qu'on veut réussir à amener sur la
plateforme des réflexions intelligentes
des médecins de la vente c'est pas
mettre le
trigger speech qu'on voit sur sur ma
Twitter tout ça mais est-ce qu'on pense
c'est que c'est ce que les gens vont
demander si on leur donne un pouvoir de
contrôler la de choisir
on en parlait avant de rentrer vous êtes
quatre on est quatre puis ça fait
combien de temps que ça existe c'est
quoi le
ça ressemble à quoi la croissance parce
que je veux dire je veux pas en arrivant
en même c'est un peu un genre de les
compétiteurs seront énormes et puis
j'arrive pas de la compétition
supplémentaire fait que ça ressemble à
quoi ça mettons rentrer en tête de même
petit start-up puis essayer de
révolutionner le truc avec en utilisant
l'anneau
uniquement
secondaire avait gardé l'anneau pour
essayer de
c'est ça
qui est plus facile à développer
c'est plus facile à vendre aussi parce
que c'est sûr qu'on est dans une
dynamique de start-up si on cherche
l'investisseur et tout ça mais écoute je
te
c'est difficile comme parcours puis à la
rigueur ok notre histoire brièvement ça
fait trois ans que Willi était fondé
puis on a passé les premiers six mois à
lever une robe de financement de
première année de financement avec un
PowerPoint et puis une bonne équipe une
des intéressante on a réussi à trouver
un point 25 millions puis avec ça on a
développé la technologie ça existe pas
ce qu'on a fait c'est
on a des chats GPT et tout mais il y en
a aucun qui essaie de comprendre ça pour
réaliser pour pour faire un feed pour
faire une plateforme à partir de ce fait
c'est ça qu'on a développé pendant à peu
près un an et demi
avec une plateforme pour aller par
dessus puis on a commencé par faire une
plateforme un peu de style social mais
sans les interactions c'est dit d'abord
on va commencer par recommander avoir
une IA qui recommande du contenu sur la
plateforme puis on investira après sur
les interactions parce que quand on
commence à avoir des interactions sur
une plateforme mais aussi un gros défi
de recommandation c'est à dire quand tu
vas sur facebook tu vois pas tous les
commentaires tu vois les commentaires
qui sont le plus susceptibles de
t'intéresser étant donné tes clics
passés fait qu'on veut être capable de
faire ça nous aussi mais
on a mis ce défilé de côté on s'est dit
d'abord on va essayer de recommander du
bon contenu puis on a lancé de la
formule il y a trois mois à peu près
sera iPhone c'est disponible sur iPhone
on va être sur Android on va sur le web
on est partout mais si on se dit on
limite le problème le plus possible
juste pour pouvoir est-ce qu'on est
capable de faire fonctionner la machine
et
c'est difficile c'est difficile on on a
des utilisateurs on en a qui adore ça il
reviennent on a même une version payante
là on essaie de voir si on est capable
de monétiser ça un peu la version
payante d'un accès tu peux créer
plusieurs de ces fils là c'est je paye
pas tu peux en avoir un stupide n'avoir
plusieurs puis on en a qui qui ont créé
un premier fils ils ont tellement aimé
que sans son créer un autre il nous
donne 8 pièces par mois pour ça fait que
ça c'est ça c'est une belle validation
métier croître à la vitesse d'un Google
Facebook on n'est pas là encore
ça prend des investisseurs
énormes c'est pas nécessairement énorme
je dirais on a besoin d'une autre phase
d'investissement qu'on a besoin puis
c'est ce qu'on est en train de faire en
ce moment on est en train de de lever ce
qu'on appelle une ronde si la marque de
financement pour nous permettre de
développer dans la plateforme les
aspects qui vont au moins donner de
souffle nécessaire pour pouvoir croire
c'est-à-dire sur les interactions le
contenu que les utilisateurs vont
pouvoir créer ce qu'on appelle user en
anglais le métier quand tu es sur
Instagram du crédit pose quand tu es sur
facebook tu crées des vidéos mais sur
sur weverly il va avoir ce genre de
poste lequel tu vas pouvoir créer puis
mettre de l'avant mais il faut qu'on
développe ça puis après ça c'est un peu
à Gumball est-ce qu'on est capable de
créer l'engouement est-ce qu'on est
capable de capturer l'imagination des
gens assez pour qu'ils viennent pour
créer du contenu là-dessus qui invite
leurs amis peut-être qu'il crée du
contenu là-dessus qui partage de
l'extérieur donc c'est des défis que
toutes les plateformes ont on va y faire
face de déjà ça qui pense qu'on va se
planter il y a des gestes parce que on a
des chances mais ce qu'on a que personne
d'autre jamais vu avant c'est cet
algorithme là qui donne ce qui donne
beaucoup d'avantages c'est-à-dire de 1
du contrôle ce que tu as pas sur les
autres plateformes de 2 tu as du contenu
même quand les personnes qui ont publié
parce qu'on recommande du contenu qui
vient d'Internet puis de trois tu as la
capacité de regrouper c'est à dire c'est
imagine aujourd'hui tu dis je veux créer
mon meilleur fil Facebook possible mon
meilleur film YouTube tu es tout seul
c'était clics qui vont déterminer tu
cliques sur des
dans la vie c'est les réflexions sur X
par du monde comme cette personne là on
peut souscrire un algo ensemble qui va
nous donner le meilleur film possible
c'est ça qu'on veut qu'on veut créer sur
Rivery c'est ce qui s'appelle les wave
ça c'est vraiment des mécanismes qui
permettent aux gens de se regrouper
autour de cette représentation là en
texte de leur expérience idéale puis
dire on va l'améliorer un peu comme un
chef Google Docs parce que tout le monde
travaillerait dessus puis de l'améliorer
de manière à avoir un fil puis votre
source d'information est-ce que vous
l'avez limité à des sources crédibles ou
est-ce que type et ça c'est un enjeu
j'imagine parce que s'il faut que
manuellement tu ailles chercher toutes
les sources que vous jugez crédible à
l'interne à place de juste ouvrir les f
harkom veratissez le web pour trouver
ses affaires là
il commence à se passe parce que quand
même au-delà de les ail comme on a parlé
tantôt j'ai pété pour créer du contenu
qui qui est généré par un ordinateur
faire le filtre de d'informations c'est
un enjeu que les haifs pas encore ma
prochaine question aussi en fait parce
que l'idée poussée du bon contenu c'est
une des super noble mais
définir qu'est-ce que du bon contenu
c'est pas une question facile à répondre
c'est pour ça qu'on se place pas comme
jeu du bon contenu on ratisse l'Internet
pour utiliser ton expression c'est
vraiment c'est une Google ça ce que j'ai
recréé c'est Google ok
on indique juste 20 000 articles par
jour c'est déjà
mais
l'idée c'est de dire on va pas c'est pas
nous qui va décider c'est quoi la
qualité du contenu c'est les wave des
gens OK puis on va leur donner assez
d'outils qui vont être en mesure de
définir ce qui les intéresse ou pas ça
va plus dans le pied récemment j'ai eu
un hitness d'un utilisateur de Rivery
qui me dit je suis un article de Fox
News ça se fait pas je vais pas voir une
fois que je m'excuse ça veut dire que tu
voulais pas te Fox News
mais il faut que tu l'exprimes à l'IACE
et puis on n'est pas encore très bon
pour aider les gens à s'exprimer c'est
dès qu'on veut aller éventuellement on
veut on veut aider des gens à midi
j'aime pas aimer ça c'est super parce
que tu aimes pas Fox News c'est parce
que tu aimes pas de contenu trigger
c'est parce que tu aimes pas cette
personne là c'est parce que tu veux des
faits pour des opinions toutes ces
choses-là peut le comprendre ce qu'il y
a pas comprendre où c'était plus dur à
dire comprendre c'est c'est quoi une
fausse nouvelle est-ce que c'est cette
là plus tendance à publier les fausses
nouvelles que ça c'est le c'est des
questions qui sont délicates puis là on
voudrait délicat pour pour quelqu'un qui
est pas l'intérêt artificielle et puis
c'est ça puis il y a même entre humains
on va s'estimer puis on se dit non c'est
pas une fausse nouvelle ouais mais là
c'est un peu stretcher ouais mais c'est
pas stretcher vous pouvez appeler ça une
fausse nouvelle c'est pour ça qu'on veut
emparer des gens pour qu'il soit en
mesure de de dire ok ben on va on va
avoir peut-être des
des sources ou des des
tiers partis qui vont décider qui vont
nous aider à définir ah ça c'est des ça
c'est des journaux de droite ça c'est
des journaux de gauche ça c'est des
journaux de fausses nouvelles de vraies
nouvelles ou peu importe et là dans nos
web on va faire référence à ça moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est un beau mélange de
contenu de droite puis de gauche sur la
question de l'avortement mettons tu
pourrais dire ça dans une wave puis
parce que
non
exactement ce genre de question là c'est
la montée des extrémistes aux États-Unis
veulent voir qu'est-ce qui se passe
là-dessus tu sais c'est pas le commun
des mortel mais il y a des questions
intéressantes que tu peux demander à
wavery il va tu vas avoir un fil de
contenu relief essentiellement puis
peut-être que parce que moi j'ai demandé
l'application j'ai commencé à essayer de
voir un peu je pense que l'étape que
j'aurais que j'ai sauté que j'aurais pas
dû sauter c'est quand ça dit
décrivez vous parce que importante parce
que ce que j'ai fait j'ai juste équipé
le but d'écrivez-vous puis je vais aller
chercher des wave qui est de
m'intéresser au titre des sujets mettons
puis le my wave et essentiellement juste
des sujets qui m'intéressent mais est-ce
que le décrivez-vous une place
importante dans le truc ouais disons à
ce moment en ce moment non ok on s'en
sert pas encore mais éventuellement
c'est éventuellement on veut que le
décrivez-vous ça devienne vraiment une
espèce de
quasiment de document vivant que tu mets
à jour constamment ou cliente t'aide à
mettre à jour qui disait je remarqué que
tu disais beaucoup de trucs sur X c'est
venu mettre ça dans ton projet j'aime
aussi lire sur
des fois tu vas pouvoir j'aime les chats
le baseball j'aime là aussi lire sur
Mars
mais c'est ça donc est-ce que l'on veut
s'en aller vers le en ce moment on le
fait pas c'est comme notre expérience de
unboarding en ce moment puis on va te
présenter des waves pour les suivre
généralement c'est
correct je sais jamais exactement ce qui
t'intéresse puis là de son film va pas
encore être ultra personnalisé il y a
quelques jours on a on a lancé une
version de weverdy où est-ce que avant
fallait que tu on a peut-être midi de
wave sur la plateforme des gens qui ont
créé des textes on en a à peu près 1000
qu'est-ce que tu veux dire des gens qui
ont créé des textes des petits textes
qui viennent définir les textes en
dessous
quand tu vois les différents wave donc
des différents filles tu vois en dessous
une petite description ça c'est
quelqu'un qui écrit ce texte-là ce
texte-là à partir du texte là les
génèrent un fil c'est ça ok si vous êtes
déjà allé se redit là toujours une
petite description du groupe ça peut le
titre il y a la description puis à
partir de la description un fil de
contenu qui est généré je comprends puis
on a un millier à peu près de ces
descriptions là qui ont été écrites par
nos utilisateurs si moi je voulais créer
une wave c'est ça je pourrais écrire ici
on partage des informations
d'actualité sur le NBA ouais puis là ça
serait les prendrai ça puis me donnera
un fil avec des informations je
comprends donc
il faut que tu écrives quand même assez
tu fais juste écrire NBA ça ressemble à
un résultat de recherche Google c'est
pas super intéressant et fait il faut
que tu faut que tu développes c'est quoi
les questions comme sur Dali puis sur
plus tu écris précisément plus il y a
des chances
vraiment pas très bien c'est écrit pas
beaucoup il faut que tu écrives quand
même pas mal fait que c'est une des un
des freins à l'adoption en tout cas ce
qui rendait difficile c'est difficile de
se créer sa propre wave décembre dernier
c'était ça à partir de cette semaine la
version qu'on vient de sortir c'est ça
peut comme Google
Canada ou peu importe c'est écrit trois
quatre mots puis à partir de là on
utilise justement chat GPT enfin j'ai
pété 3 pour générer un plus long texte
pour l'utilisateur puis c'est beaucoup
plus facile de se poser la question
est-ce que ce texte-là représente ce que
je veux comprendre par exemple dans le
texte va générer ça pourrait dire moi si
je m'intéresse aux interviews avec les
joueurs de la NBA non ça m'intéresse pas
ressemble plus à ce que tu cherches mais
elle a été écrite pour toi en partie par
période GPT fait qu'on a simplifié
beaucoup la création de Wolf et puis on
a de plus en plus de gens qui se créent
leur propre wave grâce à cette
simplicité donc vous utilisez cette
technologie là au sein de votre comment
ça fonctionne maintenant pour faire une
parenthèse là-dessus quand ça fonctionne
utiliser si cette technologie là et tu
Open Source tout le monde peut
l'utiliser
c'est en ce moment c'est c'est gratuit
c'est à dire que tout le monde peut y
aller puis s'en servir
à ce moment que tu es capable moi j'ai
chaque fois que j'ai essayé j'étais pas
capable parce qu'il y avait trop de
trafic
je peux dire un truc qui sert de chacune
des phrases que tu écris dessus pour
entraîner la prochaine version mais donc
tchat j'ai pété c'est ça prédé c'est
quelque chose qui s'appelle gpt3 puis
lui il est disponible
à travers ce qu'on appelle des en
langage des épis c'est-à-dire qu'un
programme qui est écrit toi-même peut
appeler GPT 3 puis dire ah c'est génial
à moi du texte
à partir de X elle fonctionne pas tout à
fait comme chat c'est pas vraiment un
dialogue ce petit peu plus compliqué
faut que tu faut que tu le partes avec
quelque chose puis c'est ça qu'on
utilise nous
API puis on c'est on paye à chaque appel
on donne un peu d'argent au péniac
quelques scènes chaque appel fait qu'à
chaque fois que quelqu'un utilise cette
feature sur sur notre application une
partie qui s'en va opérer
exactement c'est la compagnie qui a fait
ça du péter qui appartient en grande
partie Microsoft
mais il y avait aucun air qui ont fait
un algorithme pour jouer puis c'est avec
commencer vraiment un contrôle ok
plus après sur l'opena est devenu 55
puis là c'était que je pense là tu peux
peut-être m'expliquer comment ça ça
fonctionne mais c'est une affaire
d'apprentissage débile parce qu'il
jouait l'openhague jouait constamment
sengame à une vitesse de genre 10 fois
la vitesse d'une game normale puis
chaque erreur chaque mouvement il
apprenait à chaque fois puis après ça
l'opena était rendu trop fort il battait
ils ont battu les championnats du monde
les champions du monde genre en un an au
poney avait appris assez pour devenir
imbattable
c'est une boîte de recherche en
intelligence artificielle qui est puis
c'est un des tops chercheurs chez allé
déjà j'ai eu la chance d'aller là-bas
mais en rentrant
sont assez ouverts pour vrai
été reproduit par plein d'autres mondes
pas chat GPT mais j'ai pété 3 a été
reproduit par plein d'autres membres
parce que
c'est plutôt pour dire à une certaine
époque des compagnies des
capacité à être les meilleurs à des jeux
ok on a vu le goût on en a parlé tout à
l'heure on a vu les échecs au penélia le
fait pas
une intelligence artificielle si je joue
aux échecs mais c'est sûr que c'est on a
perdu la domination des échecs à
l'époque des castagnettes
ça arrive nul tout le temps je pense moi
je pense que c'est ça
la cassette
puis en fait la première fois que le
poker puis après ça ils sont bien
s'intéresser à aux jeux vidéos
parce que pour que tu dis si tu as un
air mais tant que mettons n'importe qui
dans son sol qui joue sur pokerstarts
triche finalement c'était une propre
dans l'anus
donc les jeux vidéos après ça ils sont
mis en fait ils sont mis là-dessus c'est
intéressant
puis en fait l'expert de celui qui a
développé des gars qui jouait à 50 jeux
de tarif c'est un Montréal
c'est ça donc on a fait Atari on est
devenu super bon à tous ces jeux là
presque tous puis donc après ils ont
décidé de faire des jeux real time des
jeux complexes
des échecs puis du gaufre et son
chauffeurs
[Rires]
mais mettons en ingénierie ou entrer
toutes sortes de domaines on va
t'arriver à un moment parce qu'on va
dire à les ailes
pour enlever le plastique dans l'océan
puis il va être capable d'inventer
quelque chose à partir de toutes ces
connaissances
[Musique]
qu'on appelle parfois la singularité qui
est puis il y a des chercheurs qui
adorent qui a derrière moi mais c'est
l'idée que éventuellement on va faire
une qui est
capable de faire tout ce qu'un humain
est capable de faire
une question encore là
je pense que la plupart des chercheurs
s'entendent pour dire qu'il y a
pas de magie dans le cerveau humain
c'est une machine qui est avec un grand
capable de simuler ou de reproduire les
capacités de cerveau humain dans avec
le système là on sent bien quand même
après avoir dit ça non mais c'est pour
ça que tu commences à te poser ces
questions là tu reviens vraiment à des
questions existentielles mais
la théorie de la singularité ok c'est à
partir du moment où on a un ordi qui est
aussi bon qu'un humain mais la première
job qui va se donner c'est de
s'améliorer puis tu partais dans une
amélioration exponentielle puis tu sais
deux jours après il y a deux fois
meilleurs qu'un humain et puis trois
jours après il y a 10 fois meilleurs
qu'un humain et puis c'est que ça c'est
c'est une des hypothèses qu'on appelle
la singularité il y en a qui pensent que
c'est pas nécessairement capable de
faire une machine qui s’améliore
constamment il y en a d'autres qui
pensent que oui
mais si on sera là éventuellement
un gouvernement des high et ça ils
peuvent jamais te corrompus ils peuvent
jamais prendre de mauvaises décisions on
peut jamais c'est le programme toujours
toutes les meilleures décisions possible
selon les données c'est le programmeur
qui peut être corrompu
dans les questions philosophiques mais
je te dirai que c'est c'est parti
philosophe là ils ont du fun normal
à Montréal c'est des questions qui sont
super importantes là qui nous renvoient
puis moi moi j'avais très de Fido c'est
assez à cause à partir à cause de ça il
faut y réfléchir parce qu'il faut c'est
s'il faut légiférer s'il faut les
encadrer il faut savoir comment
c'est fou hein on dirait c'est je t'ai
coupé
hier on en parlait aussi et puis c'est
le moment ma copine et cardiologue puis
à travers dans sur une étude en ce
moment avec un gars qui développe un air
pour être capable d'analyser toutes les
procédures puis les procédures pour
aller implanter des systèmes dans des
artères de même puis que là à force de
ramasser des données un moment donné
tout finit par se ressembler on est un
corps là on a de la mécanique
essentiellement avec toutes les
problèmes vont avoir été vu toutes les
problèmes ont été traités toutes les
erreurs vont monter analysées puis toute
cette banque de données là énorme on
aurait pu besoin qu'un humain utilise
ses mains qui risque de trembler pour
aller faire ses affaires-là qu'un humain
ait besoin de de rester garde de se
lever la nuit pour aller faire des
interventions tiens alors que tu enlèves
complètement l'erreur humaine adéquation
gencives c'est fou là
même toutes les procédures se font pour
toutes les informations sur renvoie une
place tout le monde est meilleur je t'ai
toutes les les robots va faire ça
deviennent plus intelligents mais il y
aura dans ça on le voit beaucoup en
imagerie médicale c'est l'imagerie
médicale en grande partie c'est en ce
moment c'est des yeux humains qui
regardent un truc sur un écran cancer
on délègue beaucoup à quelque chose
qu'on se moque que des fois ça marche
après
beaucoup beaucoup d'espoir sur
l'utilisation en imagerie médicale de
l'intelligence artificielle j'ai
beaucoup de compagnies qui ont développé
des TECs autour de ça moi je suis
surpris à quel point ça a pas
levé
puis on est prêt à faire ça puis je me
demande en fait je connais pas ça
beaucoup le titre
j'explique
à quel point c'est lié au fait que
justement législation en médecine est
tellement importante c'est est-ce que ça
bloque ça est-ce que c'est une bonne
affaire dans ce cas-là est-ce que ça le
bloque trop ou ça le bloque juste assez
pour s'assurer qu'on va pas utiliser des
humains comme des codages je sais pas
mais c'est une question en tout cas moi
personnellement de mon point de vue
c'est ça mais toi tu vois mettons parce
que de mon point de vue à moi on dirait
que ça va vraiment vite mettons
l'application de l'intelligence
artificielle mais de ton point de vue à
toi il y a plein de places où tu dis
pourquoi il sert pas de ça mais je te
dirai que
la compréhension d'images l'analyse
d'image ok donc on parlait là depuis le
début on parle de ce qu'on appelle la
synthèse c'est à dire créer quelque
chose de nouveau ça ça moi même je
surpris par la vitesse à laquelle ça
s'est développé ok mais la compréhension
de l'image c'est quelque chose c'est une
capacité qu'on a depuis quand même pas
mal longtemps ok
c'est quand on parle de comprendre une
image d'imagerie médicale puis dire
tiens regarde plus de regarde plus là ça
c'est les choses qu'on a depuis vraiment
longtemps on s'en sert par exemple dans
les depuis très longtemps dans les
chaînes de production pour faire de
l'analyse de qualité automatisée tu as
plein de trucs qui passent sur le tapis
roulant ça c'est pas bon ça c'est bon
c'est des technologies souvent à base
d'intelligence artificielle une caméra
puis on fait ça avec
je sais pas c'est quoi la pénétration
non plus je suis pas un médecin
peut-être qu'il y en a plus que je pense
mais je suis quand même surpris qu'on en
voit pas tant que ça étant donné que ça
fait presque 10 ans
c'est fou c'est sûr qu'il faut je sais
pas vraiment une question puis de
de faut s'assurer hors de tout doute la
machine est meilleur que
l'humains
pas faites que un erreur a fait un
humain a fait des erreurs qu'une machine
ferait pas ça on est correct mais c'est
normal je pense que c'est normal c'est
la même façon que si je te montre une
voiture autonome
que un humain n'aurait pas fait cette
erreur là on va vouloir à machine même
si les statistiques afin que la machine
fait vraiment moins de textes
je veux pas critiquer ça je suis pas je
me mets pas
c'est peut-être ça en fait qui se passe
en médecine tu as raison puis quand
c'est quand cette transition là va se
faire
va falloir qu'elle se fasse à 100% ça
pourrait pas être à moitié tu mets ton
exemple des voitures qui des voitures
autonomes si on veut avoir un système
qui fait un système qui fonctionne bien
avec des voitures autonomes qui
conduisent faut enlever l'erreur humaine
à l'extérieur de la voiture autonome
fait que sur un autoroute ça peut pas il
peut pas avoir moitié de voiture
autonome moitié de gars qui conduit je
sais pas il y en a qui pensent que ça
peut être comme transit des camions
autonomes par exemple parce que mettons
l'idée de j'en parlais avec Jean-Marie
de Conan c'est quelque chose que lui
s'intéresse vraiment beaucoup c'était
sur la capacité de juste que les
voitures communiquent entre elles pour
éliminer le trafic le trafic existe puis
si toutes les voitures prennent la ligne
exacte qui veulent puis tout le monde
sait mais pour faire ça faut comme tu
sois dans un système macro ou est-ce que
toutes les voitures disent ok voici le
trajet que je dois faire pour tout le
monde s'ajuste à leur trajet en fonction
du trajet des autres voitures
musculation
ouais c'est ça change pas mal tu sais à
la rigueur
peut-être même pas besoin de route telle
qu'on les connaît aujourd'hui peut-être
genre deux tracks d'asphalte puis gazon
autours
[Musique]
avec l'apprentissage machine cette forme
d'intelligence artificielle là qui est
la forme dominante aujourd'hui
l'apprentissage machine tu lui donnes
assez d'exemples tu lui dis voici dans
une situation voici ce que ça va faire
une situation que ça devrait faire une
situation c'est vraiment puis là la
machine finit par abstraire des règles
de ça c'est une nouvelle situation que
j'ai jamais vu mais le séminaires à
cette situation là par X c'est le pari
je devrais faire telle chose et ça ça
change complètement notre façon de
concevoir des systèmes de concevoir des
machines
moi ça cet aspect là ça me donne
beaucoup espoir ok parce que quand on y
pense
le progrès depuis l'air industrielle la
manière dont on a fait du progrès
si on a inventé des machines qui font la
job de 100 humains puis tu as juste une
quelqu'un qui conduit le gros troc
en agriculture c'est mon exemple préféré
a été capable de planter un champ de
récolter un chant de
trois personnes c'est pas besoin de
temps à l'époque près industrielle ça
prenait se prennent trop les demandes
pour faire la même job
mais la manière dont on est arrivé ça en
faisant des grosses machines neteuses
c'est pas des machines qui sont basées
sur l'intelligence artificielle c'est
des machines qui sont juste
mécaniques efficace et on a des
tracteurs c'est des machines
à modifier notre environnement pour être
efficace et
à planter des du maïs en belles rangées
droite là c'est pas la manière la plus
efficace d'exploiter de ça c'est pas la
manière la plus efficace de servir d'un
mètre carré pour générer de la bouffe
pour une population mais ça rend ça
super efficace pour nos machines donc on
va se servir pour récolter ce que
l'intelligence artificielle permet d'une
certaine manière savoir des machines qui
apprennent à partir de ce système sont
bien plus compliqués que des beaux maïs
plantés en rangées on peut on pourrait
par exemple apprendre à une machine à
récolter dans un champ qui serait planté
un peu n'importe comment puis cette
machine-là
pourrait opérer dans un environnement
qu'on pourrait dire plus organique c'est
quand même espoir que cette révolution
là nous permette de créer une forme
d'automatisation qui nous permet de
supporter la vie humaine à d'habitants
mais une forme d'automatisation qui nous
demande pas de systématiquement modifier
notre environnement une forme
d'automatisation qui pourrait
être efficace dans un environnement plus
organique plus naturel plus proche de
Planète originale vont être transformées
ça moi c'est ça qui me donne le plus à
ce sport dans le délire puis parce que
cet exemple là est quand même frappant
l'exemple que tu viens de donner du
camion puis des de la façon de pouvoir
planter et cueillir mettons de façon
plus organique ça sans faire des grosses
c'est quoi le terme que que une
monoculture sans faire des molécules
énormes faire de quoi qui qui permet au
solde de rester plus efficace mais à
admettons que tu veux prendre un autre
exemple que celui-là pour essayer de le
mettre dans un contexte qui est
peut-être plus
proche de nos réalités parce que oui
tout le monde mange mais en même temps
on n'est pas dans le champ en train de
voir de l'impact d'une permaculture
je sais pas d'autres exemples c'est des
voitures qu'on peut parler tout à
l'heure c'est une voiture qui conduit
par une IA pas nécessairement besoin des
grosses routes partout a pas besoin des
routes à 6 voix des gros boulevards
parce que sont plus sont plus efficaces
pour se synchroniser son plus efficace
pour t'amener je sais pas à l'autobus
puis
tu as pas l'impression de devoir prendre
ton auto prendre l'autobus ça c'est
comme ça suit naturellement parce que tu
as déjà qui est assez intelligente pour
être en mesure de te faire un parcours
de faire un trajet ça fait peut-être que
nos villes deviennent plus organiques
que je sais pas peut-être qu'on peut
avoir une des raisons pour lesquelles
les villes sont construits avec des
formats gris puis tout ça c'est pour
être efficace mais avec des humains qui
conduisent avec des je sais pas si on
peut on peut s'imaginer construire une
ville dans une forêt mais avoir des
systèmes qui nous permettent de se
déplacer puis d'être efficace puis c'est
obligé de raser la forêt ça va être
obligé de raser la forêt ou d'être 12
personnes
ça intéressant parce que ça revient
l'argent quelque chose qu'on parlait
hier encore on a fait un podcast juste
les deux puis on va parler plein de
sujets puis si on parlait de ces mettons
de
les problèmes d'étalement urbain en même
temps
mais ton pH disait mon vivre en ville
dans le cœur de la ville ça m'engoisse
j'aime pas ça j'aime ça la nature la
maman et puis je le comprends tout à
fait puis là on s'imaginait la ville du
futur est-ce qu'on peut est-ce que la
ville pour redevenir un peu plus verte
plus plus
moins du béton plus
friendly pour le citoyens et puis ça
donne un sport d'entendre ça des je
pense qu'on va voir des expériences qui
vont aller dans cette direction là
éventuellement en tout cas mais bon je
sais pas quelle distance on est de ça
mais moi en tout cas je rêve future
j'ai l'impression qu'on peut servir de
ces trucs là pour c'est à nous s'en
servir bien mais si on peut s'en servir
pour créer des choses le fun même si
notre réflexe initiale toujours de voir
les risques les dangers c'est les
artistes
la technologie de l'espace c'est 2001 il
est quand même référence c'est la
machine la méchante
puis il comprend il comprend le texte
ils sont un chat dit pitting ils veulent
avec un œil rouge
tu dirais que dans mettons l'idée que tu
en as où est-ce que tu penses que ce
serait à son plein potentiel versus où
est-ce qui est maintenant tu dirais que
tu as quelle phase à peu près ton
développement mettons j'imagine que
l'idée doit être infinie tu sais où
est-ce que tu peux prendre où est-ce que
ça peut se rendre mais selon quand
je pense qu'on devient un petit peu
l'os du futur c'est à dire c'est ça que
tu vas vouloir dire ok hier mon weveling
comprend j'ai une nouvelle application
que je vais utiliser mais oui explique à
cette application là qui je suis tu peux
omettre deux trois détails tu peux dire
je veux
privatiser ce que j'envoie l'autre
application mais cette idée-là d'avoir
un espèce de d'assistance si on veut
dont l'objectif c'est de comprendre
puisqu'il fait confiance
ça pour moi c'est le ending Weaver c'est
là qu'on va s'en aller nous
puissiez je suis rendu au point parce
que je le vois la technologie de la
développe je sais que ça va arriver
sociaux en ce moment ils vont ils vont
prendre cette trajectoire là non mais
les réseaux sociaux
ça va paper à côté moi je pense qu'ils
vont prendre cette direction là tu
penses-tu que l'humanité est parce que
les gens vont être prêt dans le sens que
on est prêt à être
de dépasser ça puis d'aller dans quelque
chose de plus asiatique mais je dirais
la drogue existe il y en a dehors tu
peux n’acheter
en fait il faut psy correct c'est je
pense que ça va être un peu ça ça va
être comme garde défini défini c'est
quoi ta vie puis si tu veux passer une
soirée à braser du spectacle verte sur
les divas
je pense que c'est vers ça qu'on va s'en
aller ici mais en ce moment le problème
c'est que la partie où est-ce qu'on se
dit Hey je vais être un contrôle de ma
vie à l'existence
et puis ça veut pas dire que c'est le
seul que tu dois avoir mais tant qu'on
l'a pas
je veux dire tu vas voir tu vas voir ton
thérapeute tu dis j'ai un problème
d'addiction la seule affaire qui peuvent
te dire c'est désinstalle là pour un
métier je veux quand même parler avec
mes amis sur Instagram
je pense que il nous manque cette étape
là de dire garde le jour c'est quoi la
relation que je veux avec Instagram
c'est quoi la relation que je joue avec
Youtube tu parlais un petit peu plus tôt
de d'éléments toi mettons un temps ce
film là est-ce que tu est-ce que tu dis
ouais c'est un petit peu sensation
c'est ça c'est moi je l'ai vu
l'intérieur
[Musique]
les réseaux sociaux ont trois objectifs
la croissance c'est à dire est-ce que
est-ce qu'ils sont capables c'est
quelque chose de des chances que tu le
partage ça quand tu partages c'est bon
tu amènes du monde deuxième objectif
c'est l'engagement si je te mets ça il y
a des chances que tu cliques dessus et
c'est des chances que tu écrives un
commentaire
troisième c'est vraiment de la pub c'est
vraiment comme ça qui sont construits
puis chacune de ces trucs là c'est sûr
que c'est dramatisé avec des humains en
arabe mais la vérité c'est les humains
mais c'est des intelligences
artificielles qui ont toutes des
objectifs différents et ils regardent ce
que tu as fait dans le passé puis à
partir de là il disait comment je t'aime
mon objectif c'est vraiment comme ça que
ça fonctionne puis je trouve qu'il a
fait une bonne job de le représenter
d'une manière qui est compréhensible
pour comme un immortel puis quand tu
vois mettons les efforts
gouvernementaux tu sais là on a toute
l'image de
Facebook
qui s'en va devant une commission pour
qui se fait poser des questions ça a
l'air quand même déconnecté genre le
monde ont l'air de pas savoir c'est qui
qui est devant eux quasiment tellement
les questions sont genre niaiseuse mal
éduqué et puis genre juste des gens qui
connaissent pas en toutes de quoi ils
parlent quand tu vois les efforts
gouvernementales
d'essayer de réagir ça est-ce que c'est
comme dans le milieu c'est comme un peu
une joke à quel point ils sont à côté de
la traque
il y avait des questions à cette
audit-là qui est un peu comme
c'est nous qui vient le gouverneur
mais quelque part je pense qu'on sert un
petit peu
les grosses campagnes technologies se
servent un petit peu de du fait que
c'est mal compris par plusieurs
gouvernements pour genre garder un
statut qui est pas nécessairement idéal
pour la société c'est ça on a un peu des
deux je rêve d'un gouvernement
Aires en informatique toute la dernière
place que tu penses à liste au
gouvernement tu vas avoir un objet
Google sur Facebook je suis n'importe
quoi
c'est je pense que gros manque
d'expertise technologique là-dedans il y
a plein de monde super bien intentionnés
j'en croise régulièrement j'ai de la
chance de jaser avec certains qui œuvres
dans ce milieu-là qui sont super bien
intentionnés puis ils cherchent à
documenter puis toutes mais il y a comme
des gens technologiques qui seraient en
mesure de bien communiquer l'état de la
situation
à prendre mes décisions prendre les
meilleures décisions proposer une
meilleure projet de loi
pitié c'est des compagnies par leur
modèle puis par leur modèle d'affaires
qui sont extrêmement profitables pick-up
comment qu'on
comment qu'on commercialise
un algorithme éthique
comment c'est pas par la bonne marche
finalement c'est ça
quand je te disais qu'on commence avec
la crowdlin sans grande partie parce
qu'on est capable de convaincre ces
gens-là de payer les dollars par mois
les gens aujourd'hui peuvent avaient de
dollars par mois pour un Netflix mais
c'est pour direct il faut avoir un
algorithme à toi que c'est important
c'est avec la pub mais c'est parce qu'on
se rend pas compte du coup de la pub de
la publicité sur nos vies c'est c'est
c'est ce dont tu parles c'est qu'on est
un peu enfermé dans nos dans nos modèles
actuels parce qu'il y a pas beaucoup
d'intérêt pour une entreprise qui vend
de la pub de dire ah oui je vais être
plus éthique et plus gentil avec toi
puis t'aider à te déconnecter du réseau
déconnecte du réseau tu avais envie
de mettre je pense que il y a des
mélanges que tu peux faire tu peux tu
peux dire ok on va de la pub on va faire
l'abonnement un genre de Spotify assez
bien ça c'est le but c'est quand même de
demander un abonnement mais tu prends
pas d'abonnement il va peut-être te
mettre un peu de pub il y a peut-être
besoin d'en mettre un peu moins parce
que il y a des gens qui prennent des
abonnements en fait tu peux avoir des
mixes qui peuvent marcher on a vu des
exemples
c'est pas populaire de faire référence à
la Chine mais les plateformes des mégas
plafonds en Chine à la wechat quand tu
regardes la manière dont ils font leur
revenu c'est un mélange beaucoup plus
riche que nos plateformes ici c'est 98%
publicité c'est la base la publicité il
y a des redevances sur des achats que tu
fais à travers la plateforme il y a des
SAPS il y a beaucoup de mécanismes qui
permettent à ces plateformes de faire de
l'argent puis on parlait de monoculture
tout à l'heure mais c'est un peu cette
idée-là on a des plateformes qui sont
monoculteur dans leur capacité à faire
de l'argent en Amérique du Nord ça c'est
ça fait en sorte que oups quand cette
cas qui a
un problème qui est associé à cette
manière là de faire de l'argent mais la
plateforme c'est puis toutes les
utilisateurs en souffrent
en tant que tel que tu parles de ces
différentes
façons là une un des aspects les plus
intéressants c'est que je pense que vous
le dites même dans pas de bruit c'était
comme ta lecture d'article et pas
dérangé par un institut de page de pub
de même que tu essaies de scoller par
dessus mais finalement tu finis par
cliquer sur
un attrait qui est hot puis j'imagine
qu'effectivement si l'idée de faire une
version payante une version avec pub ça
peut pallier à ça mais est-ce que les
les sites Web sur lesquels vers lesquels
vous renvoyez c'est parce que ça c'est
un clic pour le site web mais qui peut
pas monétiser parce qu'il y a pas de pub
l'autre barre vraiment ça fonctionne en
ce moment on utilise le reader mode qui
est disponible dans un dans un genre de
Mozilla Firefox et donc on utilise la
même technologie
cette cette technologie là d'en faire
Fox
tu peux tu caches beaucoup des
publicités c'est comme mais c'est une
technologie qui est quand même acceptée
elle est pas très répandue elle est pas
très utilisée
mais effectivement
on a un Internet ou des sites web c'est
mon utilise juste grâce à la publicité
fait que il faut se poser la question
est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on devrait pas
avoir une meilleure manière de
redistribuer l'argent que les
plateformes font aussi tout on devrait
justement
on est vraiment dans un Internet pourri
en ce moment dès qu'on est en dehors des
plateformes sur le Wild Web c'est pourri
l'expérience le web le web c'est ta
gueule c'est dégueu
de même tu sais puis là c'est comme
comme tu dis
dans le Journal de Québec juste lire une
nouvelle genre je veux lire c'est quoi
que c'est passé plus tu passes à travers
14 pubs de n'importe quelle compagnie je
veux évidemment je n'aimerais pas de
compagnie mais genre ça va pas de sens
notre idée nous un peu se dire d'accord
on va commencer avec des gens qui qui
sont un petit peu plus sensibles à ça
mais ça serait le fun de voir de voir un
Internet qui évolue pour
que tu dois t'abonner à toutes les sites
sur lesquels tu vois mais qu'on a des
mécanismes de redistribution qui dit
comme tu t'es abonné ici
on va leur envoyer de l'argent à partir
de l'abonnement de chez nous on n'est
pas rendu de nous on n'a pas les
mécanismes qu'il faut sur internet pour
faire ce genre de redistrucial valeur là
mais encore une fois c'est une optimiste
j'espère que on va arriver dans un futur
est-ce qu'on va être en mesure de faire
ça dans 5 ans
où est-ce que tu penses qu'on situe
collectivement ça ressemble à quoi
d'après toi mettons selon ton guest pas
mal plus éduqué que le nôtre mais dans
cinq ans on est où la vitesse que doit
faire bon je me levais
contre mon patron j'ai Google à l'époque
de trucs de Gaulle Paris contre mon
patron j'ai perdu
j'ai épaté
je pensais pas une véritable
niaiseries personne qui est que ça va
devenir rigueur dans 5 ans ça c'est pas
produit ou ça c'est où on est quatre
fois plus loin mais
où est-ce qu'on est écoute moi je pense
ce que je vois dans ma boule de cristal
c'est que cette idée là que les ordis
peuvent comprendre la subtilité de la
langue naturelle ça va faire des bons
géants mais pas juste aux applications
créatives ça va faire des bons géants à
toutes les applications qu'on utilise
parce que
soudainement on va trouver des manières
intelligentes de manière facile de de
convertir en texte les configurations la
manière dont les applications essaient
de fonctionner pour nous fait qu'on va
avoir des excel avec lesquels on
interagit en texte on va avoir des des
réseaux sociaux comme on était réagit
mais où est-ce que le texte est beaucoup
plus présent on va avoir des Photoshop
avec ça on va avoir beaucoup beaucoup
d'applications ou le texte va être de
plus en plus présent puis on va servir
de ça pour dialoguer avec une machine
pour arriver aux résultats qu'on veut
moi je pense que ça va être la plus
grosse différence dans cinq ans on va
avoir redévelopper notre
notre environnement pour
un genre d'assistant vocal qui peut tout
faire le son ça va être avec le clavier
avec la voix c'est sûr que la voix ça
s'en vient de mettre des assistants
vocaux peut-être justement un Alexa
qu'on n'est pas écœuré
mais ça va être beaucoup autour de ça je
pense de la compréhension de la langue
naturelle à mon avis c'est là qu'on va
voir qu'on va voir beaucoup de progrès
mais ça va se décliner plein de façons
différentes
là la question c'est est-ce que j'ai
pété 4 la prochaine version va être
tellement incroyable que ça va ça va
être une autre évolution
de mon côté je pense pas mais comme je
dis je
fais confiance
[Musique]
dit la même chose que il y a tellement
eu de hype par rapport à chaque gptgp4
les gens vont être déçu
en train de le développer
pour la fin de l'année puis on s'est tue
un peu ça être collé les futurs sur
lesquels ils veulent ajouter non il y a
beaucoup de spéculations il y a pas
grand chose qu'on sait pour vrai je
pense que la seule chose qui a été dit
c'est que il voulait intégrer des choses
comme Dali à l'intérieur d'un donc que
je puisse demander des images tu vas
peut-être pouvoir lui dire fais-moi un
graphique de XT mais
c'est au-delà de ça je
spécule sur la taille du modèle
d'après toi dans cinq ans ça demeure
quand même encore
des applications
sur les mobiles sur l'informatique ça il
y a pas encore d'applications
extra
extraordinaire
dans 5 ans
ça va fêter la société mais je sais pas
trop comme moi
de n'aura pas de robot dans notre salon
on n'aura pas de je pense qu'on aurait
même pas de sa driving de voiture
autonome je pense qu'on va être on va
être encore au niveau de découvrir cette
technologie en général
c'est ça en général les gens extrapolent
beaucoup quand il y a des changements
imaginent des gros gros changements mais
c'est long on pensait que l'an 2000 ça
va être des voitures volantes
la plus mauvais le plus mauvais possible
de l'histoire mais c'est sûr c'est sûr
que ça va prendre probablement ça va
prendre encore du temps mais
on dirait par exemple ça prendra le
temps que ça prendra mais qui a peu de
faim à ça dans le sens que
aujourd'hui qu'on n'aurait jamais pu
imaginer la sentence c'est jamais
impossible
pied suivant cette trajectoire là
j'ai l'impression que ça ça va continuer
d'être des grands grands changements
dans les prochaines décennies ça va être
des grands changements puis je pense un
peu comme tu dis
on a besoin d'aller voir aujourd'hui
imaginer c'est comme je l'aurais décrit
internet en 1950 Quest à faire là
tu vas acheter des trucs avec un clic de
souris
c'est quoi l'impact que ça a des réseaux
sociaux j'essaie d'expliquer quelqu'un
qui connaissent la télévision ce que ça
va être un réseau social puis comme on
va consommer des contenus qui sont faits
par n'importe qui n'importe qui nous ici
c'est c'est dur de s'imaginer ça à
l'époque surtout d'imaginer l'impact que
ça ça change de paysage médiatique
complètement je pense que c'est le même
genre de chose qu'on va voir si je serai
pas surpris que Google ressemble plus du
tout à Google ou que ça soit quelque
chose de complètement différent qu'on
soit tellement habitué à ses interfaces
textes-là que c'était assez composé une
question c'est on s'attend plus à avoir
huit liens puis à cliquer sur un bien
pièce ramasse sur une page on est
beaucoup plus dans dans un espèce de
dialogue pour répondre à nos questions
ça va chamboulé complètement d'économie
de l'Internet on en parlait tout à
l'heure tu sais si on a même pas besoin
sur la page pour avoir le pour avoir le
processus
avec le neuroling d'elonne musk puis tu
poses une question dans ta tête en
réfléchissant à voix haute plus tu dis
je me demande c'est quoi c'est quoi les
trois les trois meilleurs vendeurs en
termes de sorte de pommes puis tu le
sais automatiquement dans ta tête il y a
quelqu'un qui dit c'est mec là ils n'ont
pas moi je connais pas mais c'est genre
ces pommes là
l'information tu le loges ça va faire
des podcasts super intéressant parce que
regardez pendant trois heures sans rien
dire
à chaque fois que tu as une question
genre une question c'est quoi le plus
long poisson au monde
qui gère
il va te faire un podcast
avec la personne elle va rester
importante effectivement fait un podcast
de trois personnes qui parlent puis je
sais que c'est des c'est des avatar s de
chaque
mettons que tu la prends pas tu fais
juste ouvrir ton affaire plus en plus tu
as même pas besoin de voir de vidéo je
vais vous écouter un audio un podcast
puis si t'es pas de distinguer que ces
trois personnes qui existent pas c'est
fou là
je suis musicien de composer la musique
d'un film mais
je pourrais écouter un film enfin elle a
musique et donc incroyable puis asserdon
ben bien la scène qui me fait vivre tout
ça d'émotion puis je pourrais savoir
juste après que c'est un robot qui le
fait puis je serai genre
si ça fonctionne ça fonctionne en ce
moment il y a des playlists sur Spotify
c'est surtout des playlists de
piano de musique instrumentale un peu
néoclassique mais ton type jack écoute
ça en étudiant ou en travaillant qui se
mette ça comme ambiance et puis
quand tu fais la recherche et des noms
d'artistes qui sont là quand tu fais la
recherche
tu trouves rien tu trouves pas personne
derrière
soit c'est des gosses de Ghost Writer
Ghost compositeur
que puisse pas des failles a payé pour
leur faire des pièces pour mettre sur la
playlist ou ça ou c'est
générées
les pièces qui ont des millions de
stream parce que les gens écoutent en
bas puis que les autres n'ont pas besoin
de payer de redevance à des vrais
humains c'est vous quand même mettez
ça reste comme tu disais un peu entre
guillemets de la musique d'ascenseur
dans Ça c'est de la musique qu'on se met
pour créer une ambiance versus un
chanteur qui va et qui va avoir une
émotion puis qu'il faut huit lettres
aussi aux paroles mais dans un sens
c'est aussi ça éventuellement un peu
exister aussi
sur mes prédictions sociales c'est parce
que c'est ça que ça m'amène ta question
c'est moi je pense qu'on va voir de plus
en plus de mécanismes de de
redistribution de la richesse qui sont
pas nécessairement juste base sur le
capitalisme ok
est-ce que mes investisseurs se rendront
pas jusqu'à là
effectivement c'est une des raisons pour
laquelle tu es frustré c'est pas parce
que
c'est écrit le truc parce que tu sens
que ma job est en train de je fais ça
j'aime ça faire de la musique puis ça ça
donne que je peux être payé pour le
faire puis je suis en train mon
réalisateur il y aura même plus besoin
de moi tu sais quand tu dis ça va être
un robot qui va le faire mais ça va
quand même être le réalisateur les gars
comme on dit YouTube ça a permis il veut
dire j'aimerais aussi une musique dans
tel style avec beaucoup de cornemuse
mais pas de violon il va te faire de
quoi il y a encore un humain derrière il
y a une tension du réalisateur il y a
quelqu'un sauf qu'il y a pas besoin
d'avoir un staff de 12 personnes en
arrière puis capable de d'arriver aux
résultats similaires mais ça à qui ça
fait pourquoi ça nous inquiète
aujourd'hui en grande partie parce que
on sent dépendant de notre utilité à ce
réalisateur là pour avoir notre salaire
je pense qu'on va finir par se poser
question là je pense qu'on a réussi à
poser il y a 10 ans mais on va se
demander est-ce que vraiment la job
c'est la meilleure ou la seule façon
dont on devrait comme société
redistribuer la richesse parce que c'est
compatible avec une société qui est
automatise de plus en plus que
médecine peut faire des jobs qu'on peut
faire à manique et caresse trop puis on
va faire quoi ça va être quoi l'humanité
ça va être quoi le quotidien d'un humain
moi si j'aime pas du macramé je vais
faire du macramé il faudrait que de quoi
m'acheter mon épicerie c'est quoi ça
veut mon macramé ça me dérange pas je
vais faire des tiges je le fais parce
que j'ai du plaisir à le faire puis je
pense qu'on va on va toujours des
aspirations tu vas continuer à faire de
la musique comme ça faire de la musique
j'imagine en faire sauf que tu vas le
faire puis tu vas l'écouter avec des
chameaux tu vas mettre sur Internet puis
tu vas avoir du monde écouter parce que
il trouve ça le fun d'être écouté toi
mais ton bus ça va pas nécessairement
être de la vente puis de devenir riche
grâce à ça mais rendu là
faut quand même les acheter ton épicerie
mais oui mais probablement qu'il y a un
système de de
salaire de base universelle va finir par
risquer de jobs pour les travailleurs
fait qu'on invite les gens
download Weaverly oui participé à
l'expérience moi j'ai fait tantôt je
continue à aller plus loin plus en
profondeur dans ça mais super cool sinon
c'était des choses à ploguer des trucs
que tu veux dire aux gens qui nous
écoutent on va mettre le lien en dessous
j'imagine.com
merci beaucoup